bonjour je suis martial favre
appartenant à l'ufr l'union française
des retraités retraité depuis 2015 il
intervient à ce titre monsieur mac on
nous a appliqué sur la csg 25% a fait
augmenter au 1er janvier 2018 donc ça
c'était déjà pas une bonne une bonne
nouvelle ensuite il a lancé une europe
une réforme sur les retraites qui n'a
pas abouti peut-être espérons qu'elle
aboutira un jour si c'est encore lui
aussi c'est un autre
[Musique]
l'ufr a envoyé une lettre aux
présidentiables à tous les candidats
mise en place d'un régime universel
c'est ce qu'on demandait c'est commencer
à se faire puisque savez qu'il ya
quarante deux régimes de retraite donc
on souhaiterait qu'il n'est plus qu'un
entre guillemets sachant que la sncf
l'edf et tout ça ça va être un petit peu
plus difficile parce qu'ils ont des
systèmes de retraite très particulier
ensuite on souhaitait aussi garantir un
minima l'indexation des pensions sur les
prix
les solutions c'est je crois qu'il doit
y avoir un petit système de retraite
chacun doit faire une partie de sa
retraite vous regardez le régime de
répartition ça c'est tout à fait
d'accord mais on voit que chacun alors
c'est sûr que pour les petits salaires
ça va être très difficile pour les
moyens salaires ça peut encore se faire
pour les gros salaires je ne parle pas
ça c'est évident mais voilà l'une des
solutions qui peut être préconisées tout
ce qu'on souhaite aussi c'est qu'il ya
un dialogue qui n'est pas
ils soient pas à sens unique comme ça et
imca on l'a vu avec les îles et journée
avec covile avec tous ces expériences
cas
[Musique]